good to be here happy valentine's day to
you
and to yours
um
i'm thinking about my buddy today little
bobby lee
beautiful little guy
you know he's really he's a he's
polynesian
he's a little crustacean he's a little
cigarette koala
and uh
oh dude he would
he would breastfeed off a damn uh
he'd breastfeed off a damn uh nicotine
camel
and i'm not talking about the actual
cigarette i'm talking about the animal
he'd suck the tit of a damn nicotine uh
desert horse
a camel
thinking about him
um
what's going on dude oh you know what i
was thinking about
the doorbell
remember when you were young man
you'd be at home you'd be living your
life you know maybe fighting with your
sister you know or you know packing up
stuff to leave home you were gonna run
away from home or maybe you were playing
cards or doing something
you know having a uh
you know splitting up a caramel or
something with your cousin
and the doorbell
would ring
that when the doorbell rang
everything changed
everything
the world
the world stopped
when the door bell rang
because you it could be anything
it could be father time it could be
the postman
it could be somebody wants something
somebody's here the world came something
in the world had stopped on your
doorstep
and pressed that button
hit that all call
and you saw everybody in the family
even the dog
even if you didn't have a dog a dog
would show up and
just hear the
doorbell you quit fighting you could be
killer you could be killing your spouse
and you'd put down the knife
and say let me see who's here
man i met that i just the doorbell
changed everything we knew it was just
who is that
it could be a package it could be
somebody sending you something you owe
you what is it
it could be somebody wants to come play
you know they call hey
can ernie come play
ernie don't lose ernie
we don't have an ernie
it could be in when it it could be
anybody
when the do it it could be god
it could be
uh your real dad
it could be um
we had a pedophile dude he coming he's
the nicest guy nicest pedophile
you know hey you want to come
we're doing a kickball league
and he that you know he'd be putting
lotion on his legs
ain't got no league bro you a pedophile
dog you know but no thanks but thanks
for stopping by you were still happy
somebody came by
it was just like a game show it was like
let's the war any let's see what's
behind door number one you heard the
buzzer let's see what's behind door
number one
and it could be anything man i just
i missed that
i just missed the novelty of it just
like oh
because people don't do the doorbells as
much anymore people have a ring camera
people have fake dog bark
somebody get a fake doberman
and sometimes the battery like
wrap
you hear that
first of all that doberman sounds like
he uh
you know
he prefer you know he definitely
um
that doberman sounds like he eats his
steak with a damn little knife and a
little fork he's sounding a little
french
if you're not if you're being real
honest bro
oh
but remember that fake to scare people
off
and then we had a neighbor the batteries
got low under fake doberman and it would
be like
it sounded like an old guy just trying
to uh who had a
uh gi issue you know he was tracked up
you know he'd just been case owed out
bro and he just could his body couldn't
handle it and he couldn't pass bottom he
couldn't pass nothing out of his bottom
because you had that low battery [ __ ]
doberman in there
anyway i just missed the doorbell
and anything
just anything could happen
when the doorbell hit boy
and who was that
what's going people would run
[Music]
and i would have to stand on a chair and
look out the peephole and my sister
would just put her eye up to the low
part of the door and just try and look
through the wood
just like just it you know i'd be up she
up here and she would just
just pretend i don't know what the hell
she was doing
you know just being mystical or whatever
but anyway
i missed i just missed that god that
beautiful chime
that just damn boy
just the the lord's freaking b flat
and everybody came to this who is that
it could be maybe it's our real dad
my brother used to maybe it's our real
dad
my brother used to yell that [ __ ]
you know and we would drop something we
remember one time we all drew pictures
of what we thought our real dad looked
like
you know
just because that you know at some point
everybody wants that you know they want
their real dad to come
even if they are even if they have the
real dad they want that trade in
you know they want that upgrade
like they do at enterprise rentals baby
they want that dodge neon or better
you know when it comes they want that
dad neon or better
um
gang baby good to see you guys happy
valentine's day to you
i hope you love yourself
and uh
and then i hope you can love somebody
else man
that's important
um
and uh and yeah i went to the super bowl
uh i'm gonna tell you all about it in
just a second let's get right into it
here this is a tune that i love right
here this is uh north mississippi
all-stars drunk outdoors
[Music]
let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
cooking
come on here we go
[Music]
right there baby that is uh north
mississippi all-stars
and that is drunk outdoors
let me see where they're touring right
now so i can let you know i know they're
supposed to be up in
bend oregon soon
up there i saw
but north mississippi all-stars
okay right here they got uh
they're gonna be in uh
florida
on april 9th utah on april 23rd
and then in new orleans may 1st they got
some different shows coming up you can
check them out no
nmallstars.com tour
uh beautiful crew
and um beautiful music man people love
them
and i love them
what's going on baby hope you good hope
you're good daddy what's cracking over
here
um
not much got up this morning went for a
run you know
pretty cool
oh
dude is it just me or does everybody in
every commercial now have just you know
they got a one-legged person in it you
know what i'm like i feel like every
commercial recently
they really
they trying to wrangle in
i guess
they're catering i just
they got a lot of people that's
they missing or you know they on they
down a leg or whatever
i feel every commercial i turn around
like damn name is that kid missing a leg
the mother
you know
i just maybe it's just something i'm
noticing it's just like damn they gotta
this country we got to start getting
legs for people bro
overall
you know when i grew up people had
you know most people had two legs on
them and now i guess according to
advertising they trying to
you know they i guess they don't
so
anyway
uh yeah but yeah i went to the super
bowl bro
and it was i got it so this whole
experience this was crazy
so here's what happened
so
todd graves came on the podcast a while
back a few months back
and he's the cain's chicken man
and this fella down he'll take a chicken
and shape it into just a damn little uh
it looked like a little if uh like a
little isthmus of chicken the way he
does it
and we'll put one on the screen here as
you can see he make like a little
it almost looks like a little uh
let me look at famous islands
island shapes
they make a famous island shape it kind
of looks like
let me find one here
i guess this one is pretty good
he make a chicken looks like uh
uh
mama dick island
he makes a chicken look like a mammoth
island or molokini in hawaii he got a
real they make a chicken uh it's not a
nugget
it's like a nugget's daddy if a nugget's
granddaddy showed up you were like damn
his granddaddy is here
that's what the cain's chicken finger
looks like it's just a bit like a little
it looks like a damn somebody grill uh
deep fried or harmonica kinda
that's what it is baby you put your lips
up to that thing man
god
you could hear your freaking s you could
hear your stomach just play a damn hem
off that [ __ ]
i bet if you blew into a damn uh chicken
finger then one of them cain's chicken
finger that [ __ ]
damn you play
oh i bet a damn uh unicorn run up if
they hear the right note i just
they got a beautiful chicken anyway
so i get invited my friend cam invites
me and uh
i show up over at beverly
beverly hills hotel i think and it's
nice over there this is the place where
conor mcgregor where he
you know bought steroids or whatever i
don't know this is but this is you know
he he had been staying over there
it's nice they got rich people in there
i mean it's uh
dude you uh if you just ran up and
punched somebody in that [ __ ]
there's a good chance that person
probably would be really rich
it's that kind of space you know they
got somebody in there somebody in there
drops thirty dollars they don't even
pick it up it's not a day they cruising
they got places to go
um
so anyway we get there and uh
and this is a real i'm in a name drop
this is i mean it was just a wild day
they had
i get there coach orgeron is there
and a beautiful fella if you've never
seen him he's like a damn italian he
looks like an italian
uh
he kind of like i don't know if he's
italian is he uh he might be i don't
know he looked like a beautiful
some type of a dog like an american
bulldog or something he just
uh and he's real grizzled up he's got
that uh you know
go tigers you know he has that he just
grizzled up
so the coach is there that coach joe
burrow uh
in the deal in this uh college
championship i walk in
um
[Music]
there's like
uh nelly is there
you know
and nelly i grew up
i mean i put
dude nelly gave a lot of white dudes
hope
real talk
when
a lot of white dudes knew we couldn't
dance
we knew it was impossible we knew
we suspected i think that god didn't
want us to do it
you know you just
and then nelly came along and you're
like damn bro god wants maybe does god
is willing to
reconsider
when nelly hit it just hit hit
it hit
so you got coach oh you got nelly you
got mike thomas oh probably one of my
favorite players from uh national
football
you got
i mean just a real
dude i can't there's uh
any i don't even know where to go with
this let me think it was just such a
crazy thing so suddenly i'm in there
brian all you know i get nervous
sometimes around a lot of celebrities i
get nervous
so all i can see is the food suddenly
i'm just looking at the food and i'm
over there
you know i'm picking up food and setting
it back down like a catch and release
program or whatever like they do in the
um
uh
nature
you know
i'm moving i don't know what's going on
i'm you know i'm talk i'm looking at
stuff i'm making weird conversation
asking people like about the recipe or
something i put a plate with four
deviled eggs on it i don't even like
those [ __ ] so now i'm wandering
around with these deviled eggs you know
looking like a real creep
um
and i didn't want them and there wasn't
a lot of table area
so i could you that's what i hate if
you're at a party or some type of
mingling event and you can't set down
your dev there's nowhere to set that you
know
so you're just wandering around with
these deviled eggs
you know like you're looking for you you
know
like you
you like you got bee al's above uterus
on a little plate or something you
working
you know you working in uh
what's it called gestation or something
for satan
you juggling gestation on that little
plate
because you got them d eggs on you bro
you got them little uh
them little hen rubies baby you know
anyway so
i don't even know who they're just a
it's a crazy group of people that's in
there so i uh
some of my friends introduced me to mike
mike thomas i get to start talking to
him just talking about saints and stuff
like that
and um
and then we all leave we get into a
a like a real cavalcade
cavalcade of vehicles
like nice vehicles
just some shapes i've never even seen
one of them look like a van that uh
it looked like a van that had like a
real rich daddy
you know what i'm talking about you ever
see one of those it's like a van but
there's really no even i mean i guess
there's windows but it's like
it's like a mercedes van and it looks
like somebody's dead it looks like
whoever [ __ ] that van's mom had some
money you know um
anyway we get in there so i'm in there
it's crazy one of the jonas brothers is
in there
nick or randall or some i'm not even
sure you know
um
his spouse odell beckham's
his spouse
was in there beautiful lady
uh
odell beckham jr's brother is in there
um my friend cam is in there
um
another some lady i didn't know
and some guy from keeping up with the
kardashians that had kept getting this
kind of face remodeled you know
um
anyway we are in this
we're in this van and they got a police
escort
so dude this [ __ ] feels like
i mean it's fan you know it's crazy you
know i'm in there i'm just sitting in
there enjoying myself
next thing you know we get all the way
up to the l
to the stadium to the sofa stadium
and one thing that was rough you could
from every angle you came in from the
stadium i didn't feel like you could see
the stadium well
there was no like
good angle to see it
they had so many fences up like trying
to block covet and [ __ ] you know it's la
so they got all of these
they got people out there with shields
trying to keep cove it out and just
just ridiculous you know uh
a lot of ridiculous [ __ ] out there
um
[Music]
and so you couldn't really see the
stadium that was weird well we got lost
our group got separated
from uh
we got separated from everybody
we somehow we got separated because
there was like it was probably like 60
people in our group
and i'm leaving a ton of people out oh
um logan was there mike magillac
uh
logan paul mike magillac
their producer
oh bob mennori was there you know he's a
voice-over guy and he's a um funny guy
and he bet on the um
game he bet 75 grand on
on a team that did not win
so that was
you know you could see him going through
a lot he was changing colors throughout
the game like a mood ring bro you could
just see him
you know adjusting to the over under as
things went
uh
and then i think he really at the end he
was really bad i remember he shook my
hand he wouldn't let go he needed
somebody
he needed somebody to be there
so anyway we get we get lost from the
group and our our group gets separated
and we get stuck on the side of the
street
so we're stuck on the side in like a
neighborhood the other groups all went
inside and we're our our group got
separated
i don't know what happened i think um
i think something happened
you know
maybe a strong wind hit us or something
we got blowed off course
you know and next that's how they you
know
and that's the difference between being
christopher columbus and freaking
you know randy columbus
nobody's ever heard of him bro but he
was right there until the end a win hit
him and damn next you know he's lodged
over there in compton and just in a
neighborhood
and that was us bro we got randy
columbus dude right over off to the side
so we kept trying to find our way into
this uh
driving around into the stadium we
couldn't
and so then we just got out on foot man
and
it was just the wildest crew bro
they had um
there's some famous singers that were
there um
shawn
mendes
shawn mendes was there
and if you've never seen this guy man
he's like i didn't know he was i've
heard of his name and i didn't know
who he was
because i don't know there's a lot of
stuff i don't know
and he was there
and he's just a you know he's really
he looks like salvador dali's son bruh
you know he just real looked like an
artistic kind of
like if a birch tree went to ny like uh
nyu or something you know he really he
just
you know he's an artist
and then they had
um
this guy lion i think his name was leon
from
a band it was
what was it
a famous band third
three's company or something
it was with harry styles
and harry styles left them because i
guess they were
you know he was better looking than the
other guys whatever i'm not sure who
else was in it like little ringo and
somebody else was in the band
uh
zane a guy named zane i think or zade
and uh
yeah and harry styles said damn bro you
know what i'm saying y'all ain't really
showing up in the mirror like i am so
i'm out and he left them
but anyway
great guys
uh
[Music]
anyway so all of us
and um
jonas
and jonas's wife
and
odell beckham's brother
uh and my friend cam
and there's this lit young lady i don't
remember her name but so suddenly we we
can't get in so now we just
just start walking around so we're just
wandering around walking around the
stadium
um
[Music]
just wandering around and literally like
you know it was just crazy because these
are people that would sell out stadiums
and just wandering around everybody's so
focused on football that nobody even
notices anything
um
[Music]
so that was just a cra it was just a
unique it was just an interesting
experience that was an interesting
experience
uh
it was just crazy
kyle gurley came in who used to play for
the rams
am
oh no eddie gurley
i don't know bro
dude i it was just like
it was just the whole vi the whole
environment was just nuts
and um
yeah it's so crazy because it was such a
ridiculous time but then now that i
share about it i feel like i just
[ __ ]
made it boring
uh
but yeah i watched the game man i was so
bummed
for um
[Music]
i was so bummed for cincinnati
because if they win bro if cincinnati
wins
that does everything for cincinnati dude
that they remember that forever
people can die people on life support
would have just signed off
last night
if cincinnati had won
people said
signing off
and they'd gone back to they'd have
heard the lord's doorbell
but
yeah just not what happened and uh
and the rams
la will forget by wednesday by the time
you're listening to this la will have
forgotten that their team won the super
bowl
not the die die-hards there's definitely
some die-hards out there you know and
there's a lot of vatos out there you
know that love uh los ramas
you know
you oh you saw a lot of it
i mean i felt like there was some points
i felt like we were some of the only
white people in the place
um
[Music]
but damn cincinnati imagine you flying
home bro
and you just going back to
um to to what you know i love cincinnati
but you got it you know you get back
there they give you one more bowl of
chili dog you know like damn
damn
so i would just um
it hurt me that they lost
it hurt me i really wanted them to win
you know it just was and i don't know
it'd be an interesting climb over the
years for joe burrow and
god i just love that underdog vibe
i love that underdog vibe man
so
but yeah man it was just a cr the whole
it was just a crazy time this the whole
i was just like damn
what am i doing in here
in this place there was this
you know not that anybody's really
different than anybody else and
everybody was super low-key man
nelly was cutting up the whole time
making people laugh that dude is
hilarious
um
yeah i i i don't know it was just
interesting everybody was super friendly
and way
and it was kind of funny because you had
like a lot of you know
you know hypothetically fancy people but
once we got
lost
and
we had to just get out and walk just
through a neighborhood and then just
walk it was just like uh
i don't know it was just interesting
it was just almost like a little bit of
like um
i don't know because you had people that
normally would be escorted in through
private entrances and fancy
and then you just had them just being
totally regular
and uh
it was pretty cle it was just it was
almost like a prank like a prank or
something they would do on um ellen or
something like that it seemed like on
ellen degeneres if you believe in her
so
but man i had a nice time i made some
new friends that's what i did feel like
so
got to talk saints football with mike
thomas dude that's crazy
you know he's one of the best receivers
ever and so i was just
like a child you know and
i felt like a child
i've always felt like a child though so
um
yeah i'll tell you some other stuff let
me let me think about what else let me
let me tell you this though also that
this um
what is today
i don't know doesn't matter peloton baby
that's what i'm telling you about
you got to keep fitness fresh
you know especially these days all the
commercials even people with one leg are
doing
triathlon you'll see somebody with one
leg going uh beating their children now
where before that
you know that kind of thing was reserved
for somebody that was fully legged
and now they doing whatever everybody's
got you know
you see a one-armed person out there
doing um
you know doing uh
doing a chili cooking a chili and
stirring the chili with um that hook
you know
just hooking out that meat sauce
and it's just that's the way the world
is
so what i'm saying is you got to keep
things fresh
with your fitness and the way to do that
is to stay motivated
and keep from burning out and doing the
same thing
you know maybe you've been just doing
running maybe you need to do a little
bit of archery
maybe you need to do uh
you know uh
do some pickleball
or something like that
or just throw a heavy pickle back and
forth with your cousin
but peloton is pushing you further with
so much new
stuff on the peloton bike and peloton
bike plus
they have new classes new music new ways
to keep
your workouts fun and motivating
uh one thing they do have now with
peloton is boxing they got like uh on
the app uh they got ways you can box
they got ways that you can do yoga they
have new artist
series music selections peloton is
adding fun new
artist series classes
work out to the music of a single artist
for an entire class
from your favorite hits
to all the deep cuts from pop and rock
to hip hop and edm
there are over 100 artists series to
choose from
peloton has a workout for every day and
every schedule de-stressed from a long
day with 30 minutes of strength and 20
minutes of cardio
or do quick 15 minute total body class
before work go to one
peloton dot com to learn more that's o n
e
p e l o
t o n dot com
yeah they got a lot of great stuff if
you uh want to try something new they
have it
even though it'll be wet and chilly in
most parts of the country running will
still be a part of people's lives trying
to achieve their personal best
the wool dasher missile
is
all birds new weather repellent
performance running shoe
that wool dash or missile maybe that wdm
it's the first shoe of its kind people
this is a premier shoe
this is the this is it's never been done
before
this is the baby jesus of footwear right
here
that's right made from natural materials
and low environmental impact on the
planet
you're not gonna see this shoe 40 years
from now in a uh
you know in a duck's mouth or whatever
or sometimes you'll see a duck get a
shoe caught on his head
and he can't do nothing
and you know he
you know they find him somewhere at a
damn dsw or something he's
he can't handle his own life
that won't happen with this
the wool dasher missiles
oh they're comfortable
they're comfortable you can fly in them
i fly them all birds man
when i travel i like to put them on it
looks like uh
you could do business or
if the business wasn't going well
or if the business was hammocks you
could take a nap that's the kind of shoe
it is
it's just an all
yeah
it's an all bird man
so if you want to if you want to cruise
in a boot you want to have that cruiser
boot
and you want to be doing well in them
then get that wool dash or missile baby
from all birds this winter keep your
feet cozy and dry with the all birds
wool dash or mizzle
i'll say it again discover your perfect
pair at allbirds.com
today that's a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s
dot-com
what else
yeah i just look man we had what else
did they have at the game they had a lot
of little cupcakes these little
oh
um
i noticed you could just walk like from
one suite to the next you could just
uh even if you were just in the regular
area you could just walk into a suite
we walked into one it's a fedex company
then package boys you know them
overnighters
day in there them same day afternoon
dogs day in there you saw them those men
look tired
the same day afternoon guy like damn
they look
they've been they they put in work
the overnight guys did a little bit the
second third day air they were [ __ ]
those
they was comfortable
but yeah we walked in there and all this
thing was right next to drake the
musician his thing was right there
so i would look over and he's standing
right there i said damn bro
these people rich as hell bro
somebody in there they rich
they rich man
dude if drake even sneezed on me i put
on a neck brace
you know what i'm saying boy that's what
i would do
if that dude even patted me on the back
once i put that neck brace on baby that
whiplash
um
but it was fun man watching the game
seeing all the hype
uh
i'd never been to a super bowl and i
never even thought about the super bowl
you know i never thought about the super
bowl like us
you know i remember growing up we would
stay it was kind of late i remember i
remember i think
one year it was i felt like it was late
maybe just because i was a child
and it felt like it was late on tv
and we watched it
and i think it was the nine of the 49ers
had lost had beaten cincinnati
so damn
but that's gotta suck you fly all the
way home and they just got another warm
thing of chili for you it's nice though
i'll say this
the best food if you're if you're going
to be a team that loses the super bowl
and you got to go back to a city
nothing goes better
with losing honestly
than a warm bowl of chili dog
and that's god saying that through me
right now i know that
nothing goes better with losing than
that warm bowl of chili
damn bro
that will help
that will that will help
but god i wish they would have won it
i wish they would have won it
um i want to tell you um
we have still shows uh two february 25th
in rockford in february 26th in chicago
and may 7th in los angeles
uh those are
all still on sale
um
what else
you guys got some calls and we'll get to
those in a minute
oh
yeah dude it was just it felt pretty
magical i felt just lucky to be there
like
you know i guess you know a lot of
people don't get to go to the super bowl
and i called my good friend will teague
right before i got right before i was
heading over there because we we we
watched i think a first
super bowl probably together we were
neighbors
he's a neighbor child
and i called him i said hey man i'm
going to the super bowl dude
and it was not it was just nice it was
just you know
i don't know
just cool i never thought i would go to
a super bowl
so
just yeah it was it was it was just a
real time
it was a real time i'm pretty lucky to
have uh just opportunities like that
um
so yeah i guess i felt pretty grateful
not trying to brag about it just i mean
[ __ ] it was just bizarre dude
it was just
just the whole thing was bizarre
and then we got stuck afterwards we
couldn't leave the traffic is just
horrible so we literally had to just
hang out in the parking lot
in the back
for about two hours
just sitting there just milling around
uh
it was like summer camp kind of
and it was funny because once everybody
got kind of became stranded nobody was
like a no nobody like none of like the
celebrity people seemed like celebrities
anymore
they just everybody just kind of seemed
just like
just pretty regular
you know it was like uh
once every
yeah i don't know once
once we were all just kind of stranded
it was just like it was almost like when
the power went out when you were young
and you just
you'd all have to come together and just
be around you know
be around each other
when the power went out because you kind
of needed each other it was just a
little bit like that it was like
[ __ ]
we can't go nowhere this is
this is our new little uh
america
you know it was like a new little
so
but that was my time dude that was you
know
i don't do a lot of crazy [ __ ] like that
that was my time baby i was out there
um
what else is interesting oh i went to
see a blo i went to a blockbuster
video
this is about maybe a
maybe a month ago
i went and visited mac's girlfriend she
lives in bend oregon
if you believe in that place
i went and visited her and uh
and
they had a blockbuster
video up there the last one
and i couldn't believe it right when i
got there some guy was dropping the
videos off in the door in the outdoor
slot
some dude that i mean i can't the
overdue fines he must have had steep
sprack
um
those overdue fines were upstairs baby
them [ __ ] was upstairs
uh
and
yeah and then you go in and it's just a
flood of the past
it's like the yellow that was kind of
the yellow was a little bit stolen by
the minions kind of
they kind of took that blockbuster
yellow
and it was just like the wooden like uh
the kind of
prefab kind of
wooden uh
there was like you know what i'm talking
about the wood the paneling type of wood
you know it wasn't paneling it was like
these like
it was like kind of plywood i think but
it had like this like laminate over it
and
and you just saw the movie you saw the
thing dramas telev uh
television was a section and it was just
on
dvd or c i don't even know what the what
format it was on in there
but it was awesome you just and you saw
so many titles that was the thing
you saw all the time you're like oh what
is this one
you know
russian uh
you know bomber or something
oh russian bomber i've never seen this
and you read it
you know like somebody bombs a russian
that was like the synopsis to me like
this [ __ ] sounds
pretty bad you know
my stepdad would like it that's one of
those movies you know
like jack reacher 70. he would like that
um
but yet one thing that was interesting
you got to see all the movie went to the
different sections kids adults
uh
teens and they had drama violence
horror you go to the little section like
oh well look at all these movies you
know
uh rambo you know rambo uh
like a
rambo
remember that
or they'd have like bad attack and like
two you know dangerous bats attack a
family or something and you know outside
of des moines though
and they're like damn they [ __ ] these
bats are getting people damn these bats
um
but the one thing interesting thing i
thought about being at the blockbuster
was you got to uh
you made a choice you had all the things
and you made a choice
you went and you were like oh this one
looks pretty good i'll make this choi
i'm gonna chew
there was just so many choi you could
wander and you could choose like
it felt like you had so many
options and you got to make a choice
whereas with the streaming platforms now
you turn it on the most you can see on a
screen at one time is about eight or ten
names
and i don't really and it feels like
it's the same you could go through every
section they give you the same you know
nine options you're like damn
so that was one thing that felt
interesting at the blockbuster was that
i got to make the choice i
you know maybe i'd be in comedy section
i'd be looking to see you know let me
look over there you know they got horror
films or they got a geriatric um
you know nightmare or whatever pudding
nightmares or whatever
and you go over there and look at that
they got construction you know different
[ __ ] in one area it's just blueprints
rolled up you could read them [ __ ]
you know bad blueprints a lot of stuff
from probably like uh
areas where there's like a high water
table like damn
so if you know about blueprints some of
that [ __ ] can be very very scary
uh
but i just thought it was interesting
you got to me i felt so much more like i
made the choice at blockbuster
whereas with the streamer platforms i
feel like the choice is kind of made for
you they're making the choice in the
background
you know they're giving you these here's
12 options choose this is you know
but at blockbuster just felt like here's
all the options
and maybe because at blockbuster you're
physically moving so you're kind of
wandering through the ah there's a more
of like you doing
an action to go choose something
i don't know it was definitely i i just
felt strongly like man i miss having the
choice
as opposed to what it feels like now
more is that it gets
it kind of gets chosen for you you don't
it doesn't really
but the screen is just you know it's
such such a small screen that they
they're gonna they hit you with it
enough you might click on it
um but yeah it was crazy the new
releases and the pete the workers are up
there and they're like doing the little
thing where they take the thing off and
make sure nobody's stealing and [ __ ] god
it was such a throwback
and then they had the little candies
they had the um
there was always a couple of packs they
had nestles then they had the nestle
nugget bites or whatever
the butterfinger bites when them [ __ ]
came out dude
we i had a buddy broke into a [ __ ]
blockbuster and got six packs of those
bites
got six packs of those bites dude
of uh
butterfinger bites bro
damn dude
you'd have something to do if your
stepdad had two things of freaking bites
you'd [ __ ] wake his ass up get the
[ __ ] up stanley get up darren
get up [ __ ]
i want them bites dog
i want them bites
when them [ __ ] hit the scene bro when
bites hit the scene
when butterfinger bites hit the scene
bro when nestle bites
yeah damn dog
you'd see people in their [ __ ]
backyards training their bulldog to go
get one get that [ __ ]
get that [ __ ] reginald get that [ __ ]
get that [ __ ] boy get that bite
it's a different time man [ __ ]
was amped
and then they had the other candy it was
like the last i was like the package
just looks like kind of tropical colors
like red and yellow and or
blue
like what is that you know
oh
yeah so that was it man that was it
but it was just yeah and the p oh i took
a picture of the people working in there
and they got upset they said you can't
take pictures of the humans in there
and they had a little spot at the back
of the block bus you do a birthday in
there if you want get your friends over
there
you know if you still got enough friends
that'll come to a birthday that remember
blockbuster that's a little [ __ ]
that's diced out
um
what else you guys had some great calls
man you know i just had to tell you
about this super bowl experience it was
just
first of all the fact that just getting
like uh lost and then getting laws on
the side of the road and then just
walking in through right the regular
entrance with all these people that have
sold out stadiums and stuff it was just
baffling man
i was like this is absolutely baffling
what else man
oh i'll tell you about this right now
you should know about it that mint
mobile if you want to save uh spend less
that's one of your top goals in 2022
then mint mobile can help you it's the
easiest way to save baby
damn get that mint boy damn your breath
smells good what is that that's mint
mobile baby
mint mobile lets you maximize your
savings uh
with plans starting at just 15 a month
for people looking for extra savings
this year mint mobile offers premium
wireless just 15 bucks a month
by going online only and eliminating the
traditional cost of retail mint mobile
passes significant savings on to you
they don't have the brook and mortar
store
they don't have that broken mortar daddy
so they're giving you the savings that's
mint mobile they mint you in the mouth
son
i always said somebody should make a
mint gum where they just
drive around and shoot people with bad
breath just
ment em up
use your own phone with any mint mobile
plan and keep your same phone number
along with all your existing contacts
with mint mobile choose the amount of
monthly data that's right for you stop
paying for data you never use
switch to mobile get premium wireless
starting at 15 bucks a month to get your
plan
for just 15 bucks a month
and get that plan shipped to your door
front d who's there
go to mintmobile.com theo that's mint
mobile.com
t-h-e-o
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month at mintmobile.com
i want to let you know that uh hair loss
is killing people
they found a guy the other day in the
woods he had all of his hair in his
hands
and he wasn't alive
so you do the detective work on that
hair loss is killing people dear god
they found a guy the other day
he people didn't know his name nothing
he had two sideburns in his hand
and he was dead
you do the math folks
two out of three men will experience
some form of hair loss by the time
they're 35 jesus christ
is it fair
is it fair huh
women get these big old tits and we out
here with losing hair
is it fair god
it's me
margaret
convenient virtual doctor consultations
what am i talking about
i'm talking about keeps
i'm on it baby i'm keeping what i got
and my stuff has started to fade daddy
daddy's i've lost probably half a
mustache from each uh
each one of these areas in my head
i've lost half a damn necessary mustache
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door every three months you don't
have to leave your home
24 7 care and support
low-cost treatment start at just 10
dollars per month and keeps offers
generic versions
of the two fda approved medications
that are
able to prevent hair loss
treatment plans are affordable typically
half the cost of pharmacy prices
remember prevention is key
treatments can take up to four to six
months to see results if you're ready to
take action and prevent hair loss go to
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash theo to receive
your first month free
uh first first month
of treatment free that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash t-h-e-o to get
your first month free keeps.com
theo
yeah we just don't choose anymore a lot
of the choices are made by the machines
now
you know
with the doorbell leaving you look at it
and now they got the ring thing you can
just look and see who it is there's no
surprise you know it used to be like
every time the doorbell rang it was like
uh
it was a surprise party but you didn't
know if the party was gonna be good or
bad
or just neutral sometime it was just
somebody
i remember one time we opened the door
somebody just standing there
said they accidentally rung it
said all right bro
so you just never know
but now with the ring thing you see who
it is
you know
now with the movies you don't really you
know they give you you know the options
they really narrow it till they get you
to get the one you want
oh that'll do it
you know a lot of the streaming
platforms they'll even change the image
on the thing of the film so or the the
the project until one it catches your
eye
they'll use three or four pictures
when they did the netflix special they
would use three or four pictures and
change it and see which one gets
people's eye the most
they want to get your eye
this is different
but yeah i miss i miss the element of
surprise
i miss a little bit of going into the
place and
and also at blockbuster you drove over
there
you had to get your mom to bring you
over there she'd be out there smoking in
a car
she'd be out there smoking and yell
something get something good
and you'd be in that [ __ ] and a lot of
times she gave you money to get a movie
and you got a game that was a crazy
you brought that [ __ ] back in
mommy like what movie is it you'd be
like oh
oh
double dragon
and then she beat your ass or something
or beat half your ass
a smart mother leave you with half an
ass to sit on
i remember my mother whooped me so bad
one time i had to ride home on all fours
on the back seat
because i just had too much damage on my
ass
too much ass damage
praise god baby
praise god
um
what else
we got some calls that came in uh
let's see what we got
here's a couple that came in um
here we go let's hear this
what's that nto it's ryan from up here
in louisville kentucky what's up ryan
up there in louisville baby and that's
where my boy uh cedric jumped out
and uh
surprised everybody at that
party
and um
and stole all those purses baby praise
god i hope he's doing well
out there
uh let's hear more brother onward
so
my girlfriend and i've been together for
about two years now we moved in together
oh damn okay so you did it like that
amen but she had a cat and her cat was
kind of an [ __ ] you know
yeah man that's uh
that's a cat
so i was like [ __ ] let me get a cat
so we got me a cat
months go by
and now bro you gotta you you you
why'd you let her get you a cat
that's
if she already has a cat
do you need a cat man like why do you
that's like the sadie hawkins of like
the animal kingdom kind of like why do
you
i don't think you needed to get a cat
man because
i mean i've never been like i don't know
i'm not letting some if my
if i have a girlfriend and she has a cat
i'm not letting her get me a [ __ ] cat
you keep your cat
sondra or whatever
your name is
i don't want a cat
so i'm trying to support you here man
but let's hear more
yeah cat
months go by
and now we break up in that time no [ __ ]
dude
you break up because you that you let
that you
and i'm gonna lose this i'm gonna use
this term loosely bro that's a loose
term you letting that match
cat you up you was done the second you
say yeah baby i'll take a cat
on your behalf what dog
you out here cat having for these hoes
baby damn you can't live like that
god don't want you to god don't want you
out there
going home to some cat you don't even
love
and when you do that [ __ ] a woman sees
that oh he willing to get that cat
all right
that's
onward tell her to move out
she ends up taking the [ __ ] cat she
takes her cat and my cat yeah you never
had a cat bro don't you understand you
never had a cat
you was a pawn baby
you was a pawn you was a pet shop pawn
you was a fella you they they ladies
that lady used you
she'd probably have a bunch of pictures
of men on her phone that she may get
cats
and you wanted him now look at franklin
he's got it look at him look at that
tabby look at ryan over here with that
little siamese
come on baby you're better than that
let's hear more
she takes her cat and my cat
i think better carries goddamn cuts than
she ever could
she's doing this just to get back at me
i mean
is she wrong
or am i just bitching
man i
you can't be doing that bro
you can't take on an animal because some
lady needs you and wants to see you like
that she wants to look across the room
and see you with your cat and she got
her cat
that's just
you you tougher than that
you know
i don't want some lady looking over and
i got a cat that she made me get
bro
i'm upstairs baby if you need me
i'll be over there petting my dick no
i'll be over there petting myself
i'll be over there licking my own skin
you know i don't need so i'll be over
there with a damn parrot or a damn uh
pit bull baby or a damn gay friend
that's a prize fighter that's italian
baby i'll be over there with a [ __ ]
billy conforto dog
i'll sit over there with a ghost i don't
need to be sitting over there with a cat
that a woman made me get
damn bro good luck dog
and be lucky she took that cat
i used to live with a guy over here
kenny bruh and he would uh get stoned
and make his cats jump up into little
boxes and [ __ ]
and i'd have to sit out there and watch
that [ __ ] see and i was that's and i was
you
i was you man i'm watching i'm [ __ ]
out here this dude he's [ __ ] high and
i'm out here you know and i'm [ __ ]
high watching these cats in the dude's
boxes what the [ __ ] am i doing
and wondering why i'm lonely i'm out
here watching some man teach a cat to do
box tricks and [ __ ] in our living room
and neither one of us were really
gainfully employed
dear god bro praise god
all right let's hit a couple of these
man and see what we got here
hey theo my name is kate and i just
listened to your episode about
ayahuasca and your mom and starting to
feel your feelings again and i was
incredibly touched
thanks for the call kate thank you for
reaching out uh the hotline as always is
985-664-95003
onward
and
i think i was kind of getting teary-eyed
a little bit throughout a lot of it um
it reminded me of my own experience not
thinking i had feelings for decades well
i mean not decades but a long [ __ ]
time
and once i
started feeling them again um
having
an interaction with my dad where i was
just crying
and so devastated by something and he
was looking at me like i had three eyes
like
i remember him saying like do you want
do you want a beer
do you want a glass of wine do you want
to go out to dinner
and i was like no i just want you to
[ __ ]
look at like just listen to me or hold
me or
cry or
show kind some kind of semblance of
emotion like don't try to
patch this up with food or alcohol you
know so i just to say like
a lot of us have had this experience
realizing that our parents
couldn't have this open emotional
awareness with us and it's a really
shitty thing to realize and i think it's
kind of like the equivalent of grieving
a death
like what you might be going through is
some kind of grief for
something that you didn't receive in
childhood that you needed and didn't
have the words to express or know that
you needed at the time
yeah look look i appreciate the call and
uh
and she's talking about the last episode
if you didn't hear i was talking to just
about the the experience that i've had
um
with trying to get off antidepressants
and
uh
doing ayahuasca and just the
all that's come up during it and and
everything um
yeah you know i think it's tough a lot
of us
when people
we we
well there's a couple things for one we
tend to yeah when people there's so many
things that can distract us from our
feelings now
there's so many just
so many things
that can just
you have a feeling you reach for a phone
you reach for a cigarette you reach for
um a video game you reach anything
to not have this kind of human
experience
uh
and i don't know how
we stop that
especially now with phones i mean we're
just addicted if there's any there's no
bigger addiction than a phone it just
it's almost like we've let electronics
beat us kind of in a way or we've let
like
i don't know
we've let
here let me listen to what you said
again
i remember him saying like do you want
do you want a beer
do you want a glass of wine do you want
to go out to dinner
and i was like no i just want you to
[ __ ]
look at like just listen to me or hold
me or
cry or
show kind some kind of semblance of
emotion like don't try to
patch this up with food or alcohol
yeah i think there's yeah so i think
there's a lot of yeah we try to patch
things up we try to we don't know what
to do
and some parents come from a generation
where feelings were they didn't there
wasn't feelings
there was no responsibility
we're at such a place in the world
especially in like this capitalist
country of america
where
where we're all kind of so satiated
and there's so much less for us to do
physically a lot of times that we're
[ __ ] sitting around here you know i'm
sitting around here uh
you know
sunbathing in my feelings
you know literally just sitting here
eating feeling soup it's like i'm just
um
and i'm not knocking it i'm not
but i think a lot of our parents are
from a different generation different
time
you know where things still needed to be
done with the daily routine and the
responsibility and like
um
you know people used to have kids
because they needed them to help on the
farm that's a few generations ago but
it's not that
you know it was just a different you
would lose more kids in childbirth it
was just
there was a lot more uh
things were more industrial in some ways
and more natural
in some ways
i think nature and the reality of things
was a lot closer
because there weren't so many things to
separate you
and
and people used to get sick and die more
there was a react there was just a
reality was so right there
um
and now it's like everywhere you know
there's a medicine for everything
everybody stays alive till you know
we live in
longer so there's some semblance of
that
you know we all have these desk jobs
where we're sitting here looking at
ourselves and looking at feedback it's
just about us it's just this mental loop
where it's probably unhealthy for us and
so yeah i think we're just in different
times you know i think it's so i think
that's part of it
so sometimes our parents they just
didn't it wasn't it's not a part of
their
language
i think for some of them it's not a part
of their language
but
yeah
you know this whole this whole
experience going through the ayahuasca
and trying to stay off antidepressants
has been tough
because i just had all these feelings
that had never been anywhere they'd just
been stuck in me so it's like
and i could never always remember asking
myself how do i feel about this i could
never i couldn't even get a feeling
it was always just this kind of
comfortable space you know we're
semi-comfortable space
but yeah thanks for sharing kid i think
there's you know a couple of things that
play one where our parents had they they
didn't have that
the luxury if it is a luxury
of
wandering through their feelings so much
um
because they had to actually deal with
stuff on the outside they had real
things to deal with
whereas today on average
a lot of that has been
it's pretty comfortable
for most people in america
so
you're just kind of left like the only
the last frontier is inside of ourselves
now
and so that's where some of us are
maybe exploring and then since we're not
using our bodies and stuff as much
then there's just
you know i think there's like this weird
time where
we don't
a lot of us
you know our nature doesn't know what to
do
um
[Music]
i think there's a weird thing going on
where we don't feel of use
and so uh
i don't know
i don't know exactly what i'm saying
um
[Music]
i don't know sorry i don't know exactly
what i'm saying kate but i i do
appreciate your call and i appreciate
you uh sharing your experience
um
[Music]
let's get another caller or two that
came in man uh
here we go right here
hey theo this is rose i just i'm from
dallas texas and i just want hey rose
from texas yeah the yellow rose of texas
that used to be a thing i don't know
what it was i think it was a garden or
something over there
and i don't know what happened to it
probably that roundup ready monsanto
killed a lot of that [ __ ]
but um
i love you thank you for calling in rose
uh let's hear more
i want to let you know
that i listened to your last solo album
and i'm the mother of five sons no
daughters and i consider myself a pretty
loving mother but damn
you really got that
your uterus is a damn little [ __ ] gun
baby that thing's firing out wieners
baby damn bro
praise baby praise
thank you for sharing man um ma'am
or young lady i don't you know
who knows uh but thank you for the call
let's hear more you have five sons
but the words that you said really spoke
to me about being there for them not
having an answer not having a suggestion
just sitting with them in their pain and
i'm trying to raise strong men
but
i needed to hear that and i think that
not only will i be a better mother but
you'll help me raise better men and i
just really appreciate your
vulnerability
and your
just access to your feelings and
willingness to share that um
it means a lot to all of us and i hope
you know that gang gang
gang rose thank you
uh
yeah and i think i could have been extra
sense i could be extra sensitive about
this the the relationship in my
in my relationship with my uh mother
because i didn't have a father
relationship so you know
and i was also a sensitive kid so you
you put all that stuff together
um
you know it it can just
it can really be kind of like a little
android like a perfect storm kind of
like that movie where they killed that
guy
uh
ahab or whatever i don't know what i
don't know what the guy's name but
but anyway um
but thank you for sharing yeah and
that's cool you got five sons that's
awesome
yeah i think that's just
yeah i don't know how to have a bet i
mean
i don't know how to have a better i mean
i guess i do but it's like
i don't know i don't know what
you know
i don't know
but i appreciate that um and i don't
have any choice
but to be where i am like
you know i wasn't feeling good there's
nothing i could do about it i've tried
been trying everything um
so i just have to be i think on this
space that i'm on right now
and uh
yeah i think you sound like you're doing
a good job just from your voice
uh
and i hope you are
and um
yeah and i wish you the best of of
of love and connection over there with
your children
all right um
yeah and i want to thank everybody a lot
of nice messages and stuff uh
from
uh last week's episode and just for the
support
you know um
just for the support i'm feeling excited
this week i'm going back to the
ayahuasca treatment i feel
you know uh
i'm feeling good taking care of myself
um
yeah
but i do appreciate it you know it's
just been it's a wild journey like
you know i i don't know it's like
this is just where this is my life
yeah i'm just really grateful for the
support man a lot of nice words
um
you know a lot of people going through
their own journeys and things and
trying to keep themselves healthy and
well
and i don't know what it is i don't know
if it's that
uh
maybe humans we don't feel of use we
feel disconnected from nature i'm not
sure i don't know if
if america has much more mental health
problems than other places or emotional
wellness problems you know
because i also don't know if some of my
problems feel like their mental health
or if they're more like just emotional
wellness you know i mean i took a long
sabbatical on medicine
from
having feelings
so
you know when you
when you really
open that back up it's gonna be
a ride um
[Music]
but
yeah
just grateful man grateful for a lot of
beautiful messages uh
and uh and just for supporting the
podcast
um
excited to do some shows got to do some
shows last night uh this uh two nights
ago
um
what else is going on i'm feeling a
little bit overwhelmed i got a busy day
that i got to go do some other stuff and
this week is going to be busy
i'm going to vegas to interview
um
we got somebody coming up on the pod so
going to interview them
and
then going back for the ayahuasca
treatment this weekend so
you know just a lot a lot going on
getting out on tour next week and um
yeah
still kind of high from that super bowl
was a long you know it was up late
and uh
yeah i don't know i'm feeling
i'm feeling pretty chill man
you know i'm feeling grateful that i
have things to do
uh
and
[Music]
and this is where we are baby
this is where we are um
yeah so i just want to thank everybody
and uh what else
that's it
that's all we gotta hope you're doing
well and happy valentine's day to you
and uh
i hope you get a little chocolate or
something you know i remember when i was
young my mom used to always give us
these chocolates
she would give us that little russell
stovers daddy damn that little [ __ ] had
about four four in it i think
and one year we had a little bit of
money she gave us that [ __ ] has six in
it damn
and i love them all except for the one
with the strawberry cream in it
i would trade that one in my younger
sister lie to her about what it was oh
yeah you'll love this one
and uh
and that was what it was baby that's you
know
that's that's capitalism that's how it
works
um
i think let's let's get out of here the
way that we came in man i really like
this tune this is north mississippi
all-stars uh i love you guys uh be good
to yourself
and
damn dude i got to go to the super bowl
bro that's crazy
so that's really really
i never would have thought it
if you told me about the super bowl a
lot of said damn bruh no way
so but that's not what i'm saying now
uh you guys be good to yourselves baby
gang
[Music]
outdoors
[Applause]
[Music]
hot
let's go get drunk outdoors
[Music]
if you got money you can get a little
better if you've got money
[Music]
you